think Jake is uh I put him in a top five  best troll [ __ ] talkers in the game it's  uh and he goes up against people above  him and he hangs it's not like he's  calling our people below him bullying he  goes up and he he can go go up against  anybody no I don't think uh Tate wins  here whether he wins or not like okay  let's just say Tate fights and he wins  what are you gonna say  what are you gonna say if Tate fights  and he wins what changes you're a world  champion kickboxer yeah exactly right  but but if but if Jake goes and he wins  what do you think Jake and more  importantly what does Logan say my  younger brother  listen I I I don't think you do this  fight I don't think it's necessary I  think this whole thing is plenty outside  of this I don't think you do the fight